whoa whoa whoa oh wait don't eat it
don't eat it don't eat it don't eat it
don't eat it
[Music]
hi my name is owie and today i will be
selecting a date based off of their pet
i moved out to the u.s when i was four
and i've been here ever since a year
after i immigrated here uh i got a dog
her name is fairy i've had fairy for
about 20 years now and so at this point
she's just family she's not even a pet i
think pets and their caretakers kind of
go hand in hand like they feed off the
energies of each other the more energy a
pet has for example i would assume their
caretakers like has just as much energy
all right i am ready to meet the pets
oh it's bunnies
oh cool
hi
hi i'm vi and this is tony and this is
braxton my pet rabbits had tony for five
years now and then he just fell in love
with braxton in june so i've had her for
two months now rabbits are actually the
most misunderstood pets since they don't
bark or meow you always have to be
paying attention to their body language
i think the rabbits kind of represent me
with both of their personalities when
tony first met braxton he was so shy and
freaking out and then she was just all
over him and i think i'm a little bit of
both because at first i can be kind of
shy but then when i'm open up i'm like
that's my man these bunnies are my
number one so when i'm looking for
someone to date i'm making sure that
they don't have a hay allergy and that
they're treating them as well as i am i
don't know what to do with like bunnies
i hope he's not scared are bunnies like
this big usually everyone always says
that everyone's always surprised how big
bunnies are
yeah this one has red eyes it's crazy
it is not how you pick up a bunny
hi
i'm tony and this is my bun wife braxton
as you can tell from our names we're big
music lovers our favorite activities are
going on walks to the beach and cuddling
while watching tv
whoa wow tony seems to like him he
doesn't always like guys i was in my
mom's life for five years until one day
she realized i needed to go from
bachelor to husband and braxton and i
have been inseparable ever since we hope
our mom will find love as true as ours
you know like those type of people that
are like really into harry potter i feel
like that's the type of person that
would have rabbits um harry potter's all
right i like watching the movies so
apparently i can give these bunnies
bananas i'll give that a shot
want a banana
okay
all right
i'm sorry
banana
oh he's straight munching tony loves
treats that's like his favorite thing do
you want a banana
no
they're all gone now so i don't know
what's going on
they would he totally freaked out if
they didn't like him so they're just
excited it's a good sign actually
braxton
tony where'd you go
i'm gonna go around
hi oh no come back
oh no they're too excited
tony and braxton are very independent i
feel like whoever's the owner is
probably really independent and stuff
like that he said that i'm probably
really independent because they're
independent which i like it's great
meeting you guys it's my first
experience like petting
bunnies wow
you are fluffy like you got some gnarly
waves hi i'm carolina and this is my
baby leo i've had him for nine months so
leo is a little crazy but he's a good
time he is always stealing my stuff um
he's always getting into trouble i think
it's just you know growing pains i think
if the bachelor meets leo he might think
i'm insane because he is non-stop just
energy 24 7. but that's not too far from
who i am so i feel 100 confident putting
my love life into his little paws i
think my dog is a great reflection of me
so if anyone picks him then i would be
flattered to go on this date
hi
kind of energetic i don't think he's as
excited to meet leo as i would have
anticipated hi i'm leo i may seem very
sweet but my real attention is to steal
your socks and your heart i love a good
tug of war and of course i'm the life of
the party wherever i go like my mom i
require lots of attention but i promise
at least with us it's never boring very
fluffy but doesn't jump on me so that's
kind of cool in a way yeah leo's being
surprisingly chill around him has his
mind of its own just doing his own thing
now kind of got bored of me so
yeah leah's not interested does your mom
have hair like you
you don't know okay i wish my hair was
like leo's sit leo sit
okay yo does not care he knows how to
sit wow she's like very calm he is so
chill i don't get it he looks very well
groomed i mean like you have to be well
groomed in order to keep this like cool
wave thing going on he's very friendly
so i'm assuming the the mom is very
friendly as well yeah that i am like i
would see the owner being more of like
going out on hikes a lot very active i
don't go hiking too often i have a bad
knee
wow
adorable
it's biting his tail
so now they're starting to bond a little
i think we made a good connection though
i don't know if he necessarily likes me
but
i kind of like him he's cool
no you don't like this okay
he's a very cool dog i like him a lot
i'm not as cool as leo for sure leo it
was nice meeting you
bye
so i met three different animals today
of two different owners on one corner we
had tony and braxton the two bunnies
one didn't really like me that much but
the other one
kept eating the banana tony tony was
cool hey i can teach him a little bit
about how to interact with rabbits in
the other corner there was leo the dog
it was mellow but added a little bit of
like a spunk to him cool dog indeed i
assume
the tony braxton caretaker
is really into books leo's owner's
probably i'm assuming
the more energetic one out of the two
okay i've made my decision the pet owner
that i
will be
meeting with
is
oh my god come on tell me
okay
i'll
go with
i'll go with leo
because of you know the hair the overall
like chilled out vine but also has like
a little bit of like energy to him i'm
excited to meet leo's honor and see if
uh my theory checks out i'm excited to
meet the bachelor whoever i date has to
love my bunnies and since he doesn't
it's not meant to be hello
hi i'm karolina nice to meet you ali
nice to meet you i know i'm not as cute
as my dog but i hope i'm not too
disappointing deleo is cool like that's
the coolest yeah it's like a very chill
out like dog but he's not chill
so i think he's just matching your
energy oh
if we on a date that means like he's
going to be like even more energetic
probably i don't know if you can keep up
we'll see about that so
do you want to go on a date
yeah let's do it we are
done with the
first state
how would you say it went
pretty well i think my theory
about the dogs
and uh their owners
kind of worked i think yeah yeah i think
you got my energy right i don't think
you
read leo
we'll see what happens
[Music]
you